hey kleinen mäuse zähnchen heute fange
ich mal den block schon morgens an
nikolaustag ich werde sie zum frühstück
um 7 uhr 30 maschinen von gestern
ich kann immer noch nicht glauben dass
jetzt ein los war mein gehirn kann es
auch einmal verarbeiten also der grund
warum ich morgen sollte schon creme ist
war mental die stiftung startet sondern
startet er ja nur um 13 uhr zum blocken
streiten aber jetzt startet er doch
heute startet er schon um 37 denn das
einzige was ich jetzt noch schaffen
werde sind daten zu übertragen und dann
muss ich auch schon los denn ich habe
heute eine pressekonferenz für den
youtube space gibt hier in berlin so ein
ort für youtube manchmal sind da auch so
events und aktionen und heute ist eine
pressekonferenz ganz ehrlich ich habe
mich über die anfrage voll gefreut
ich dachte mir so was von dir denn also
noch gar nicht so interessant sein was
hatten sie heute zum frühstück ein
lahmacun mit salat von kräutersoße nein
ich meine heute zum frühstück rheinland
schon mit salat und kräuter soße ja die
daten übertragen dauert jetzt auch
einfach
drei millionen jahren wie die diese
pressekonferenz geht von 9 bis 12.30 uhr
und danach muss ich nach hause
wenn ich um 13 uhr zu hause und muss
sofort schneiden damit um 17 uhr
du kannst du schminken und premier
online gehen kann und ich habe heute
noch den ganzen plan möchte dieses jahr
für nicolai seinen nachbarn alle eine
überraschung geben und zwar an die türe
für nikolaus und weihnachtsmann oder wir
mögen nicht an sich ja irgendwas halt
irgendwas halt in dieser art ich finde
ihn nicht man sollte öfter seine
nachbarn eine freude machen ich meinen
mann lebt mit seinen nachbarn so viele
jahre unter einem dach und was wird uns
das wohl sagen
guten morgen timo studie ist noch gar
nicht schlafen
guckt mal liebe freunde hier ist
sich dieser blogger stapel neuer
influenza bist du geworden
praktisches make-up noch in meinem
esther schmid wieder mal vollkommen
übertrieben
ja ich bin besser und ich bin youtuber
sind weißen haaren machen soll ich
glaube ich ziemlich einfach
[Musik]
here comes the sun
also ich bin jetzt fast da ist es kalt
es ist wirklich richtig richtig kalt
geworden meine kamera ist richtig
ausarbeiten licht im hintergrund ist
deswegen sind auch glaube ich die
aufnahmen von gestern mit kevin hart und
jack black also dunkel geworden ich
hoffe man sieht aber und hört sie ja ich
meine das ist ja cool es ist schön dass
unterwegs ich glaube hinter mir auch
nicht ich kann so tun als ob ich in der
öffentlichkeit bloggen kann ohne dass es
mir unangenehm ist sagt schon wieder die
kamera app im hintergrund das licht ja
gerade podcast das podcast du froh dass
ich ein bisschen abwechslung können
nicht immer nur gemischtes oder so war
die konkurrenz bei allen eine chance
geben das sage ich immer dass ungefähr
das gleiche
ich habe es gefunden erfolgserlebnisse
am morgen okay wir sehen uns drin
nicht fehlen darf kann es dass youtube
space natürlich kann ich will
nicht so dass in meinem kopf schon mal
rat name steht aber
[Musik]
und hier werden dann die ganzen klasse
leute werden hier in lübz wazv erleben
mein name ist er auf 90 30 jahren
deutscher dem ich hingekommen sind neue
space vielen dank an die create a wir
haben studieren ein einstündiges
programm
wir werden ihnen drei top listen von
diesem jahr präsentieren
ja ich mache das ja schon ein bisschen
länger also ich hab mir vor drei jahren
insgesamt fast ein rekord zum fünften
mal eingestellt du hast es geschafft mit
150.000 menschen in einem livestream
wird ihr zu kommen hamadi hast du das
geschafft das war weiß keiner so genau
aber ich bin jetzt übrigens oft bewegt
werden gleichzeitig habe einen kanal in
schwangerschaft und geburt babys erstes
jahre ich bin mutter von vier kindern
ich habe im januar 2018 zu beginn wenn
dafür die schwangerschaft habe ich mir
gedacht wenn ich eigentlich seit jahren
oder selbst zehn jahre
ich war die erste die ein kind hat in
meinem freundeskreis sind die ganze
liebe ist einfach mutter bei uns einfach
mutter sowieso alle meine freunde
beraten und dann sollte ich mir einfach
gesagt so jetzt mit ihrer vierten
schwangerschaft mache ich das auf
youtube unternehmen die mama ist in ganz
deutschland mit von hofft ist woche bis
heute noch mal ganz kurz in der praxis
was du damals
ich freue mich dass das ganze zeit also
im november habe ich jeden tag
adventskalender ausgefragt und im
dezember nehme ich jetzt meine zuschauer
jeden tag mit deswegen für mich auch
gerade
und damit gleich oder meine zuschauer
begleiten dich dadurch den tag um einen
kanal ist irgendwie so eine gute
mischung aus alles und eine bunte tüte
ich bin der fan davon dass man sich
immer wieder neu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich freue mich sehr dass wir den
aufsteiger des jahres 2009 10 unter die
aufsteiger 2010 hier haben das team von
besitzer im kopf beschrieb oder zweite
auf märkten welche die ersten sind die
online gegangen jetzt habt ihr 158
millionen euro eingesammelt
das sagt keiner in deutschland schnell
geschafft und ihr seid deswegen auch die
auflage des jahres geworden hätte sich
für menschen hat so reicher menschen
habt ihr denn erreicht dieses jahr jetzt
auch technisch ich glaube 86 millionen
ist das echt heftig als wird das in so
einer großen reichweite gerichtet und
mit so großen resonanz darauf
oh mein gott das mikro war die ganze
zeit ich drin also jetzt alles schon
gesagt ich bin gerade nach hause
gekommen
also presskonferenz lief gut ich bin
anscheinend heute bei rtl explosiv
ich weiß nicht also ich kann glaube ich
nicht schauen also falls sie mich heute
am fünften bei rtl exclusiv gesehen habe
dann schon gerne in die kommentare
und ja ansonsten muss ich heute noch
schneiden
es ist jetzt 13 uhr ich habe mir damit
ich den stress des todes ist irgendwie
reingehauen und jetzt machen wir türchen
nummer fünf auf so ich glaube schon
alles gesagt gerade auch das ist das
türchen nummer
na ja und ich habe herausgefunden warum
meine kamera gestern als es wichtig war
jetzt so gut aufgenommen hat ich hab
halt die kamera automatik gehabt sondern
einen film modus
ich hatte schöne aufnahmen haben können
mit jack black und so und jetzt habe ich
so dunkle oder für dich fotos hinum
april das brauche ich heute da - das
sind so studenten mischung aber das ist
viel teurer ist ihr wissen
kyu tele 5 gegen aus seinem alltag die
du normalerweise nicht beachtet es kann
sich dabei um objekte oder auch person
handeln der zweck dieser übung besteht
darin dankbar zu sein und die scheinbar
unbedeutenden dinge des lebens zu
schätzen es sind dinge die zu deinem
leben beitragen aber wenn die du fast
nie gedanken verständnis als beispiel
könnte man den strom nennen denn deinen
koffer und energie versorgt post boden
deine post in frage dich wie
funktionieren bestimmte dinge auf welche
art tragen sie das hat er schon gemacht
oh ja aber der blick weil ist schon
vorbei ja kommt gerade zur
weihnachtszeit machen wir das alle mit
den paketen bei jedem paket was wir
bekommen machen wir uns richtig bewusst
was ist eigentlich heißt oder was
dahinter steckt dass dieses paket bei
uns angekommen ist oder kein problem ist
jetzt auch ein großraumbüro geworden bei
uns wir treffen uns immer mittwochs also
gegen 13 uhr
seit mittwoch ist das stehe morgens
nicht los ich muss noch für die nachbarn
das thema dieses videos ist eigentlich
dass sich nikolaus spiele weil das video
kommt morgen online und ich will für
meine nachbarn überraschungen haben die
tür
15 stunden wie auf den beinen auf den
beiden nach zwei stunden marie noch
fröhlich meinen nachbarn die
überraschung machen was ist dieser tag
heute
warum dachte ich das loch ness dieses
jahr einfacher wird kann mir das mal
jemand sagen man hat nichts gegen übel
verletzt
[Musik]
meine damen und herren es ist 16 uhr 52
und das video exportiert das heißt es
ist in zehn minuten online und timo
macht jetzt ein adventskalender auf ok
[Musik]
lecker schmeckt wie mal schön kaufst du
was für mich kannst du denn eigentlich
mal lag ich denke ich manchmal dass ich
mir diese stolze mama wenn ich gerade
liebesdrama ich werde wahrscheinlich
werden auch nach dem kalender extrem
fett werden ja wie weitere werden extrem
kalt werden
naja egal was davon wichtig hallo danke
bitte schön dass er sieht aus wie der
dahinter regeln er aber du wirst mit 7
die hatten vorher dazu kopiert timo wie
mache ich das denn jetzt
ich wollte noch mal einen nachbarn so
weihnachtsüberraschung vor die tür
machen und nicht jeden machbar
ein stück kohle vor die tür überall sind
eigentlich voll cool wir haben schon
öfter hier mal eine party gefeiert
die haben noch nie was du ja stimmen und
nikoläuse werden doch schon cool oder
ich meine dass nikolaus kommt man
nikolaus timo war heute drohne und timo
hat tolle aufnahmen gemacht
dann muss ich dann ist jetzt der nächste
step nicht in meinem leben sondern in
diesem blog zum supermarkt zu fahren ein
supermarkt supermarkt super super laden
bringen danach sagen wird sich dann
bekomme ich komm ich kann das kann sie
ich kann schon und auch du hast dann
gucken wir mal fotos angucken
[Musik]
reingekommen erfolg ich habe noch nichts
gegessen heute den ganzen tag nicht das
ist fakt 15 uhr nims supermarkt gibt
super lebensmittel
ich habe gar nichts für dich findet auch
so doch wir haben ja in unseren ab ins
gelände
ich hab ja ja ja ich habe gerade gedacht
dieses schild ich habe ja nicht an dich
gedacht das ist echt das freund
geschenkt ich bin ganz aufgeregt
morgen kann ich endlich aufmachen ein
very excited warum kommt jetzt plötzlich
wieder die energie ich glaube gerade so
das stimmt dass ich die positive energie
hereingebracht ich glaube ja schon an
energien also video hochladen
ach so stimmt wir sollten uns mal
anschauen wenn ich dass ich irgendetwas
skandalöse ist rein gemacht habe also
falls ich mal fragt hier sitze ich immer
mache meine voiceover für die blogs also
ich hatte gerade einen zwei stunden
abend schlaf der mich selbst vom
richtigen schlaf abhalten wird
und jetzt möchte ich aber unbedingt
nikolaus spielen deswegen geht er jetzt
einkaufen
ich bin auch gespannt ich war noch nicht
ganz genau was ich hole ich klar also
schoko weihnachtsmann ist auf jeden fall
klar
verschiedene tabletten aber nur ein kind
kohletabletten und dann fragen
untereinander kriegt eine kohletabletten
und die anderen nicht das ist nämlich
interner große team aus
die leute da draußen gar nicht stellen
denn niemand erfahren
das ist quasi von der hunde zu sehen wir
dennoch nicht mehr interesse hast du
schon
also war ich muss kurz achtsamkeit übung
machen ein drittel ist voll
jetzt muss ich mir auf dem süßen spor
aufhängen oder ich hab noch
weihnachtsgrußkarten ich könnte sie aber
weihnachtsgrußkarten was drin
ich würde meinen kopf vielleicht auch
ein bisschen schneider muss so kalender
schiff genau suchen durch die kitschige
und drauf fragen was sind kann endlich
los der krise bezeichnet machen 1 27
dazu kleine dicke haut dazu besser du
bist du bist du so ein ding will ich die
ganze zeit h18 wir fangen herr der ringe
an
[Musik]
du liebe stehen der gebäude wurde also
mission nikolaus geht voran
ich habe jetzt so weihnachtliches ticker
noch von vor ewigkeiten
ich habe noch mehr weihnachtliche
sticker ich habe viele weihnachtliche
sticker und dann habe ich noch so
karteikarten und ja schreibt jetzt liebe
grüße an diese nikolaus sachen für meine
nachbarn
ich weiß auch nicht ganz genau was ich
schreiben soll aber das bestimmt wäre
für mich gerade so ein bisschen wie so
ein der seine kinder mit so einer
adium ich selbst gebastelt oder
jetzt war sie noch durch schnürchen
machen sonst geschenk nation
ein bisschen übertrieben ich merke
selbst aber ich freue mich das ist
wirklich also dass es eine selbstlose
tat einfach was nettes eine nette
botschaft weil sonst schreiben sich
nachbarn immer nur so wäre aber gestern
so laut wie report werde
[Musik]
ich bin echt so aufgeregt dass ich mir
den nikolaus mit so aufsetzen
als ob man das nicht hören würde
ich kotze vor aufregung
[Musik]
ich bin so unangenehm wenn mich jemand
dabei entdeckt wurde
ich bin gestorben so unglaublich lange
und dann sind manche umgefallen wäre
nicht auch so lang gelaufen bin war es
geschafft